talk about wounds and fears of our main
character how severe should they be if
they're too extreme will it scare the
viewer away well first of all keep in
mind that the wound is always something
that occurs before the story actually
begins it's in the characters backstory
so rarely in a movie will we actually
see that wound the only reason we would
see it is if there's either a prologue
that shows the wound so if you take a
movie like twister where we see her
father's swept away by a tornado and
then we flash-forward to where she's a
grown-up but we know that is the
wounding experience that's going to
affect her that's affecting her now or
it might be in a flashback hitch is a
good example of that I'm not really that
fond of flashbacks as a rule especially
to reveal wounds but in that movie it
works I think because it's such a funny
flashback as well as touching and it
just establishes such an important
quality for the character of hitch
because we see when he was in college he
had his heart broken and that's when he
acquired the belief if I fall in love
with anybody it's gonna lead to a broken
heart which leads to his identity which
is I'll help everybody else fall in love
but I don't do that that's not for me
so I think it's more palatable if you
want I don't think you're gonna scare
anybody away with it because oftentimes
we won't see it also keep in mind you're
not going to announce the wound in most
movies at the beginning sometimes we're
aware like in Sleepless in Seattle the
opening shot is a man holding his son's
hand over a grave saying mommy died
that's pretty direct but oftentimes we
don't learn what that wound is until
well into the story it's at least half
way through Good Will Hunting before we
find out about the abuse that he
suffered when he was a child or find out
the details about his father taking a
belt to him in gravity it doesn't open
by saying I'm sorry about your daughter
dying
it comes out gradually after the
opportunity when the space debris comes
through and destroys this the ship and
so on and then Ryan is talking to the
George Clooney character and revealing
what it was that happened back on earth
that led to her daughter dying and why
she's carrying that around so it's not
going to be abrupt it's not going to be
right at the top of the story most of
the time and last of all one of the most
effective ways I think to reveal the
wound is through dialogue it's
oftentimes more powerful to hear about a
wound that the characters suffered that
it would be to actually watch it on the
screen a great example of this is the
movie LA Confidential
by the way I just read Curtis Hanson who
co-wrote and directed the movie just
passed away yesterday so this is the day
we're filming this thing and that was so
sad because I think it's just one of the
great American movies and one of the
great American screenplays but the wound
for bud white the Russell Crowe
character is when he was a child he
watched his father beat his mother to
death with a tire iron while he was
chained to the bed and then he was left
there with the body for two days that
would be such an unbelievably gruesome
experience to watch on the screen but
it's such a beautiful moment when he
finally reveals it because it's right
after the midpoint he's just made love
to Lynne the Kim Basinger character and
it shows how they have gotten closer
they are connected more at this level of
essence because finally he's opening up
about exactly what the pain is that he's
been carrying around so long and what
led to him becoming kind of this brute
cop who still does everything he can to
rescue women so I don't think it's
something to worry about in the way you
said I just think it's something to
skillfully weave into the story so that
will feel more affinity the character
and also so it will lead to the reason
for the character's identity you're
saying that we don't have to show the
wound or explain what happened but at
some point we do reveal it or or is it
never are there some stories where we
but it's never totally revealed what
that wound is or how it happened yeah
there are movies whether it's never
clearly stated Titanic is that way it's
very clear what her identity is and what
her her essence is she longs to be
passionate she longs to live a fulfilled
passionate adventuresome life but she
stuck with this mother who interferes in
her life and this rich guy who's really
a jerk and so it never says well when I
was a child this happened or when I was
an adolescent this happened we can infer
some things the inference I make is that
probably she either had no father or the
father abandoned them early on that's
why the mother is so intent that her
daughter find a rich guy to take care of
her
but it's never really stated fully so
you can go without revealing it as long
as we get a clear idea of what the
identity that has resulted for the hero
is the main thing though I think is you
as the screenwriter or you as the
novelist need to know what the wound was
you need to know your backstory for your
hero well enough that you can say this
is what wounded them in the past and
this is why they're the way they are in
the present
you